with one of the most exciting games of
the year tonight it's been an
adventurous last 24 hours for your team
losing to the pat coming here how badly
did this team need to get a win tonight
no this you don't need you don't need to
get the win you don't have to get a win
you want to get a win I think we came in
here we understand it was a back to back
obviously guys going to be tired we knew
Chris has is going to only play in the
first half guys want to compete play
hard and and try to get a win this was
your first time going up against Victor
wanyama what was your impression of how
he played tonight he's he's unbelievable
unbelievable Talent can score at at will
anytime he wants uh plays the right way
place to win uh it was great playing
against him well congratulations on the
win thanks for that show it was fun to
watch thank you so much Kev our producer